right let's get a shift on
[Applause]
[Music]
okay folks so there you know I was a hot
I was pretty much done and set for most
of the rest of this month but then they
had to go and drop another Doctor Who
trailer and completely throw me off and
this is one this one honestly in a way
feels a little bit more like a teaser
then the last one did because it feels
much more tiny snippets across a whole
lot of stuff and it doesn't feel like as
focused a look and now though there's
anything wrong with that I but my
general what I'm used to is that the
teasers are more you know first trailers
are more you know zooming in on on I'm
sorry I got a back with getting my head
straight first trailers in my head are
usually more like bits here little bits
get to feel and then later trailers you
close in more on the characters feel
like they did the opposite here which is
I mean that's fine that's a way to do it
there's a lot to like I'm I like the
look that the whole thing is going for
there's a lot of sense of scale and
scope and a lot of these shots we get
there's a sense of grandeur a sense of
epicness which I always like Doctor Who
to have when it can and it looks like
that they're really aiming high for that
end of it and that that is reassuring to
me I like seeing that that makes me
happy
so I like all that ah the effects look
really good like that where there were
quite a few effect shots of quite a few
different things from spaceships to dust
storms to giant spiders and it all
looked pretty dang good and to see you
know that it's a wide variety and not
just like one shot that they Lane grande
that looked really good like okay well
they put all the money in that house the
rest of it kind of look no this was nice
and spread out and that's that's good I
actually think that Doctor Who effects
wise has been pretty solid for most of
its run for the time that was made it's
nice to see that continuing forward
because it's it's always a rough
sign when there is a notable sort of
aesthetic or budgetary downgrade you
know when you when you skimp on special
effects you can tell especially if you
don't adjust the stories you're telling
accordingly so I I didn't see any of
that don't get a ton more sense of the
doctor herself and we don't really get
enough off the companions to get much
from them we get the sense that they
trust her because we've got that whole
thing of she's in charge says who says
us and they have all immediately got her
back and that's kind of a volume of
number of volume of numbers and that
kind of lend of support that's cool and
I like how automatic and response was
from them that said that is gonna lead
me to one of the things that made me go
a little bit and that is that hope that
moment I don't know if it is because we
don't really know much about the
character but it feels like it could
feasibly be the kind of thing that I've
said I'm worried about which is putting
a lot of emphasis on how being a woman
makes things different so like
historically and at least in modern
Doctor Who not always as much in classic
but a monitor doctor who certainly the
doctor has tended to come into a
situation and basically command the room
and the times when that has not happened
has been have been pretty noticeable
like say midnight but by and large the
doctor comes in and when the doctor
decides to take charge he is able to do
that so if they are gonna put a lot of
emphasis on well know people aren't
gonna defer to the Star Trek's now it's
a woman like maybe once assuming it's
not to cringey I really hope that's not
gonna be a recurring thing and I really
hope I'm over reading that into this but
that leads me to the other thing which
sort of allows me to retroactively Lee
talk about the really brief teaser that
came out what a week week and a half ago
or so that people wanted me to talk
about but I decided not to because Mike
I don't want to
with that so there's the tagline that I
really really wish they weren't using
and it's the it's about time and I know
why it's there because somebody and
their marketing decided it'd be a cute
pun because that's the sentiment of
decent chunk of fans in regards to a
female doctor plus you know the show
it's about time travel so it's about
time ah except its first of all it's not
as clever as they think it is and and
then it feels like it feels
unnecessarily confrontational as a
sentiment in terms of putting a front
center in the marking especially because
this is not the first time we've seen it
because we saw it in that teaser from
before that and some people really
wanted me to talk about which I think
it's kind of come to be known as the
glass ceiling trailer where the doctors
in you know kind of a cathedral you know
with a big glass dome and that shatters
she kind of looks at the camera goes
sorry and then it's about time and I
don't think there's anything inherently
wrong with any of that but I just wish
they didn't do it not because I think
it's bad and not that I even think it
necessarily puts an emphasis on the
things that I've said I'm afraid of an
excessive emphasis on the doctor now
being a woman and making a big deal out
of it when I think just having it be
would be better we'll see
but this marketing tagline doesn't make
me more worried about that because I do
understand the separation between the
creators of the show and the people who
market it that's pretty much never the
same people and yeah I I'm not gonna
hold Chris Chibnall and his writing
staff responsible for what the marketing
team has decided to push with this stuff
so I don't I don't it doesn't make me
worried in that sense you know that one
scene that I mentioned that I'm a little
like okay well I'm gonna keep my eye on
that but like this
giving stuff doesn't make me worry but I
still wish they weren't doing it because
it's it's poking the bear and I don't
know what what they think they gain out
doing that at this point because we we
are at a point where whatever Doctor Who
fans who are putting their foot down and
are not going to watch the new doctor
because it's a woman they like they've
made their choice already so to continue
to hammer on something when I don't mean
to make it sound like a war but
basically when the lines are already
drawn when people are already picked
their sides just do something like this
feels both prematurely celebratory and
also like I said kind of oddly
confrontational it's like they're poking
the bear on it and I just I just would
rather they didn't and again I don't
even necessarily have a problem with you
know the weight of the significance of
this I do appreciate it I'm not trying
to downplay it but it's it's really just
a matter of what is gained at this point
by needling the thing I really I really
just want the product to stand on its
own and because I don't want the show
itself to be making internally within
the narrative a huge deal out of this
that means that for the marketing to do
it just I feel it's distracting I feel
they're they're setting it up to let
somebody down there either because
either the show is going to back up this
kind of work in which case I suppose the
marketing would be at least
representative and that's not gonna be
what I want to see or it's going to or
they're putting out this kind of
marketing and it's not representative of
the show but then they're making the
show appear more confrontational II
political than it in fact is and it's
just one of those marketing decisions
that again I think they just came up
with what they thought
acute cymbal cute bit of symbolism and a
cute tagline and just yeah I think I
think there are people who that you know
I made the lion in the sands thing and
thinking back on it that's not the right
term because line of the sands implies
that there's only two sides to be on but
they're really honored the whole thing's
a gradation so while there are certainly
the people who said Doctor Who's dead
and are still leaving comments on random
and dr. video who Doctor Who videos that
I do going you know Doctor Who rest in
peace 2017 like oh for God's sake look
and you know they made their call a long
time ago but that doesn't mean that
everybody who didn't immediately go I'm
not watching is 100% on your side I
think there's a decent chunk of fandom
that is either skeptical or cautiously
optimistic because I think anyone who's
being realistic there's a lot that can
go wrong here not because it's a woman
but because it's a massive change to the
show and when you're doing massive
change to any ongoing thing that can go
very wrong and to sort of there's a
difference between going forward with
confidence and going forward cocky and
this this it's about time tagline to me
feels like it crosses the line a bit
into cocky and cocky cocky can turn
people off and it can turn the people
who are you know trying to be open to
you but are a little bit skeptical off
because it can feel like you're getting
a lumped in with the people who already
bailed and are very adamantly against
this and yeah it I just I just wish they
didn't have this tagline and I wish it
hadn't appeared more than and more than
one piece of marketing and that's that's
kind of where I land ultimately on that
whole Anna bear probably now spent more
time talking about that then about the
trailer itself but I mean honestly
there's not too much you can grab from
the trailer it's just tiny bits tiny
moments I like the vibe off her
performance she looks
running with that coat I like the final
moment that sort of you know I love that
I that felt very nice just lack of a
better term just felt nice so I'm gonna
wrap it up there I'm really excited for
the for this series to get started so
bring it on so that's gonna wrap it up
for me folks second trailer for Doctor
Who series 11 have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff to do there's buttons and
there's links down there including one
to the patreon maybe check them out if
you feel like it so that's gonna wrap it
up folks remember you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]